[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi, and
welcome to Episode Number
136 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Mark Mandel, and I'm here
with my colleague, Melanie
Warrick.
How are you doing?
MELANIE WARRICK: Hey, Mark.
I'm good.
How are you?
MARK MANDEL: I'm good.
I'm not actually here with you.
You're in Stockholm.
MELANIE WARRICK: I am not where
you are, not today, anyways.
MARK MANDEL: Not today.
Today we've got some
pretty amazing content.
We're talking about robots.
MELANIE WARRICK: So we're
talking with Raia today
about reinforcement
learning and the research
that she and her team have
been doing out of DeepMind.
And this, of course, also plays
a role in the robotics space.
So that is a fun thing
to be diving into,
and I'm glad we've got
her joining us today.
But as always, we start out with
our cool things of the week,
and we will end with our
question of the week.
And so question
of the week is how
do you connect a
Google Cloud Source
repository to an existing
Git / because that
is where everything
is at with code
is you gotta be able to
have a Git repository,
and you've got to be
able to connect it
to wherever else you're
going to store it,
and in this case, the Google
Cloud Source repository.
So Mark, cool
things of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Sweet.
MELANIE WARRICK: First we want
to mention the AI Adventures,
the new video that Hui Fang, one
of our colleagues has put out
I think about a week ago.
And he talks with
Megan Risdal, who's
also one of our teammates,
about how to make a data science
project with Kaggle.
So you should check that out.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
We recently also
announced a capability
to predict your future costs
with Google Cloud billing
cost forecast.
You now have a
nice visualization
and some numerical
declarations of basically
what your projected
forecast for your costs
are going to be for the month.
MELANIE WARRICK: It's
always a question.
MARK MANDEL: So
this can give you
some nice prediction
for the sort of costs
you can be expecting based on
your current usage patterns.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
And another cool thing of the
week that we want to mention
is the link in our show notes
for the Kaggle competition
Winning Solutions.
This is something
that was put together
by one of their
community members,
I think in conjunction with
some of the other team members.
But I'm not 100% sure,
although it says in their site
a listing of the different ones
who were involved, somebody
I know out of HUOAI.
So basically they
pulled together
all the winning solutions, or
many of the winning solutions
that you see in
Kaggle competitions.
And I'm constantly
telling people,
when they're asking where to
get started when they want
to explore data sites,
to explore Kaggle,
look at the different
projects that are out there.
So this is very
helpful if you want
to look at what's been done
and see if you can recreate it.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
And people should remember
Kaggle is on the GCP Podcast
Episode 84 back in 2017.
So if you want to learn
more about Kaggle,
definitely go back
and check that out.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Yeah, you guys talked
to Wendy, which was great.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Finally, we announced
a new project,
a new open source
project called a Jib,
which is for building
Java Docker images better.
I like this.
This is a really cool Java
tool that has integration
with Maven and Gradle.
So you can just add the plug-in
to your build, and basically
you have your Java
application containerized
in no time at all.
I really like
these sort of tools
that make these kind of
workloads a lot easier
to manage.
So that makes me happy to see.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Yeah, the containers.
Got to get a little
container plug in there.
MARK MANDEL: I got to get
some containers in there,
absolutely.
Awesome.
MELANIE WARRICK:
All right, Mark.
I think it's time for
us to go talk with Raia.
MARK MANDEL: Let's go do that.
MELANIE WARRICK:
So this week we are
thrilled to have with
us Raia Hadsell, who
is a Senior Research
Scientist from DeepMind.
And we're going to talk
about reinforcement learning
and navigation.
So thank you for joining.
RAIA HADSELL: Thanks, Melanie.
MELANIE WARRICK: So Raia,
can you tell us a little
about yourself, your
background in this space?
RAIA HADSELL: Sure.
I've been at DeepMind
for the last four years.
I lead one of our research
groups in the deep learning
area, work on problems in
robotics and reinforcement
learning, lifelong learning,
a bunch of different subjects
that I'm excited about.
Before this I worked
at SRI International.
I was at Carnegie Mellon
for a little while,
and before that I was at
New York University, where
I did my PhD with Yann LeCun.
So a lot of neural
networks trained
in different ways over the
years for different things.
MELANIE WARRICK:
What inspired you
to go into robotics
research to begin with?
RAIA HADSELL: I
really loved the idea
of writing code and
coming up with algorithms,
but then going out
in the real world
and seeing if they
worked or not.
If I did robotics, then I
could take my algorithms out,
I could run them on a
mobile robot that we had,
and I could see whether or not
the robot ran into the tree
or went around the tree.
First problem of mobile
robotics, avoid the trees.
Robotics brought me into machine
learning because we really
wanted ways of making the
robot behavior be adaptive.
I didn't want to run
the robots on paths
that all looked the same
or on roads with markings.
I wanted to run the
robots in the forest
or on paths in the grass
or through shrubbery, where
it would have to identify
where the obstacles were
and where the clear paths were.
And that required
machine learning.
That required
adapting over time.
MARK MANDEL: So that
sounds really interesting.
I don't know anything
about machine learning.
What allows you to do that
kind of thing that lets robots
basically, what, see space?
RAIA HADSELL: The
way that we did
it then was to sort of
collect data all the time.
We'd label that data
as to whether or not
it was the ground
or an obstacle,
and then the robot would
learn that immediately.
And it would train
a neural network
to make a decision, either
good to drive or an obstacle,
bad to drive there.
And that worked well,
and it allowed the robot
to adapt and to
change its decision.
But what we actually do now
is reinforcement learning.
Maybe I should
explain the difference
between reinforcement
learning and machine learning.
MARK MANDEL: Sounds great.
RAIA HADSELL: People
are probably familiar
now with things that
we call AI systems that
might do things like
recognize objects and images
or help make some decisions.
And that's done, usually, using
supervised learning, where
we have a big data set
of, for, instance, images,
and each of those images
has a label attached to it,
like this is an
image of an apple
and this is an image
of a monkey, et cetera.
And you train a neural network
to produce those labels
by teaching it, and the data
set stays exactly the same.
And that's really important to
make the learning work well.
What if instead we
want our algorithm
to take actions in the world?
And the only feedback
we're going to give
is a reward, either a positive
reward or a negative reward.
So instead of giving labels
and sort of drawing data
from a data set, we
want an algorithm
that can interact
with the world,
have feedback that comes as
positive or negative rewards,
and change its
behavior based on that.
That type of learning
is both more powerful,
because then the algorithm's
actually interacting
with the world and
able to take actions,
for instance,
driving instructions.
But it's also a lot harder.
Say I want my robot to be
able to drive around a room.
It has to make all
of these decisions
about when to turn left and when
to stop and when to go faster
and when to get slower.
And then at the end I say,
that was good or that was bad.
You hit things or you did well.
And the algorithm then
needs to figure out, ah,
where did I made the
mistake, or where did
I do the thing that was good?
And it needs to do something
we call credit assignment.
Get a good reward, and
I need to figure out
how to change my neural
network to incorporate
that information.
And that's what we call
reinforcement learning,
and it's very much the same
as the way in which we think
that, for instance,
a dog learns to do
a trick by using a positive
reward when it does the trick.
But it is quite different
from supervised learning
or other types of
machine learning.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
I know that DeepMind
is well-known for the
experimentation and exploration
with Atari games.
This is sort of
a starting point,
or a well-known
point when we start
talking about reinforcement
learning, which games granted,
Mark, is all your
area of expertise,
so I know you love
that kind of stuff.
One area you've been studying
is dealing with navigation.
What helped drive the current
research that you have?
I mean, it sounds like obviously
your interest in the space,
your exploration around
spatial awareness in the past.
How did you decide to go down
this path with reinforcement
learning?
RAIA HADSELL: For
things like Atari games,
you don't need a lot of memory.
You need to learn
how to play the game.
So we talk about an agent
learning to play the game.
That's the usual term that we
use in reinforcement learning
is that the algorithm
that's changing over time,
is getting rewards,
is called the agent.
And it interacts with
an environment, which
could be an Atari game
or it could be a maze,
in the case of navigation.
And navigation really brings a
whole other level of difficulty
to it because you need
to have a memory of where
have I been before?
Where am I right now?
Where am I trying to get to?
So you need to incorporate
all of these different cues.
And when I'm talking
about a maze,
I'm not talking
about a maze that you
get to see from the
outside, that you
get to see the whole thing.
No.
Imagine a 3D hedge
maze where you can't
see beyond your current space.
And you need to try to have
that spatial representation,
that spatial
understanding that says,
I know where I've been
before and I know where
I'm going to try to get to.
And I'm going to try to learn
the path to get to that point.
So I just thought that it
was a really interesting area
of research.
It was very challenging.
And so we did some
research that showed
that we could train our
algorithms to solve these 3D
mazes, and that we could
train agents to do that where
the mazes were sort of a game.
We actually used the
Doom engine to create
all of these different
mazes and try
to just have the agent
get from wherever
it spawned to a goal location.
And if it gets to
the goal location,
then it gets teleported
somewhere else
and it needs to find
its way back again.
So it both has to do
exploration as well as
remembering where was the goal
and finding its way back there
very quickly.
And we trained algorithms,
we trained agents
that were better at
doing this than a human,
and we did that by incorporating
memory into the algorithms,
into the neural network itself.
And that's a bit different
than what we think
about traditional robotics.
Algorithms for doing
navigation usually
start by let's build
a map, and then we
can run a path-planning
algorithm on the map.
And then we can send
the control instructions
to the robot to follow
that path through the map.
Instead, here we're doing it
all intrinsically with instead
of an explicit map, we have
an implicit representation.
And that's much more the
way that we navigate,
which I find really interesting.
MARK MANDEL: So you talked
about both the simulation
and robotics in the real world.
I'm guessing that you do your
training in the simulation?
How does that work
with the translation
between both things?
I'm guessing the real world
is a little more complicated
than the simulation?
Are there challenges there?
RAIA HADSELL: Yeah, absolutely.
The real world is very hard.
Robotics in general, with
reinforcement learning,
is very hard.
I mean, why is it hard?
The world has a lot more
noise and complexity
to it than the simulations
that we create.
And that makes
these algorithms--
which are visually based, right,
you're looking at an image--
that makes it awfully
hard to operate.
It's also hard because the
amount of data being used.
So the agent that can learn
to navigate in mazes better
than a human can learns
for over a billion steps
in the network, which
means it's about a week
of 24-hour training.
And that's not just one
agent, but that's usually
about 128 different
distributed agents
learning at the same time.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Multiple different agents
distributed across the network
exploring similar spaces.
RAIA HADSELL: Exactly
why we use simulation
is because we can run again
and again, we can speed it up,
we can run it 24 hours a
day, and we can understand
which algorithms work.
MELANIE WARRICK: Just
curious, are using TensorFlow?
RAIA HADSELL: Yes.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
So in terms of the
work that you're doing,
the streetwise navigation
research that you guys
were doing, you were using some
real world data, is that right?
RAIA HADSELL: So after
working for a while
with these simulated mazes,
like I said, using Quake or Doom
engine, they were really
good to work with,
but I really felt like we
weren't really demonstrating
that these algorithms would
work in the real world.
And we wanted to
have at least some
of that real world
noisiness and complexity.
And somebody here that I
work with, Karen Simonyan,
said we have Street View.
And Street View is a really
interesting set of data.
And probably everybody
who knows Street View
has used it at some point.
This gives you an
on the ground, sort
of panoramic, interactive
interface with a map,
with a city.
And so we said what if we turned
this into an interactive RL
environment and trained
our agents there?
We took Street View in
an area-- for instance,
all of New York City,
most of Manhattan--
and we turned that into an
interactive environment.
So on each frame, on every
step, then, the agent
gets an image
that's just like you
would see if you were using
Street View but without any
of the arrows or
other information.
And it gets to decide
on an action to take.
It can turn in a circle,
it can look up and down,
or it can take a step.
And if it takes a step,
then it will move forward
to the next panorama in Street
View if there is an edge there.
And that allows the
agent to actually walk
across New York City and
try to find different goals.
So we made different
sorts of games here
and tried using
the same algorithms
to see if the agent could
learn to explore New York City.
MELANIE WARRICK: And what
were some of the algorithms
that you used?
RAIA HADSELL: So we've
been mainly using
an algorithm called
Impala, which
is an actor critic method
of reinforcement learning.
It works very well distributed.
So you can think
about it as there
are a bunch of different actors,
say 128 different agents.
They've all got a copy
of the neural network
that we're training, and
they're all somewhere
different in New York City in
this virtual environment Street
View.
They're all in different
parts of New York City,
and they're all trying to find
their way to different goals.
And that's the
sort of game play.
And then there's
one learner, and all
of the updates to the neural
network come to that learner,
and it puts them all
together in a nice way
and learns over time.
And that's the algorithm.
MELANIE WARRICK: It's almost
making me think of, like,
a scavenger hunt.
RAIA HADSELL: Yeah, it is.
That's a bit how
we thought of it,
that it would be a scavenger
hunt or a sort of a taxi
task or a courier.
But you have to go from one
location to another location.
If you get to that location, you
get given a new place to go to.
And we just watch the agents,
after they're trained,
zooming all over the city.
The interesting thing was
when we started training
with Central Park, in the
middle of this big area of play,
usually in New York
it's pretty simple.
I'm sure some people know New
York City or have visited.
It's pretty simple.
You go down the block.
There's this very
regular street layout.
But then all of a sudden
there's Central Park.
And there's only three,
I think, different roads
that cross Central Park.
So the agent actually
needs to learn, ah
if I need to get
across Central Park,
I'm going to need to take one
of these streets that go across.
Similarly in London,
the agent needs
to learn where the bridges over
the Thames, over the river, so
that it can get from one side
to the other side efficiently.
And it does learn
all of these things.
MARK MANDEL: So I'm
guessing that what
you were talking about before,
with the agents weren't given
the map beforehand, they
had to learn that while they
were driving around.
RAIA HADSELL: Right, exactly.
So the agent never
sees the map, never
gets the advantage
of seeing the map.
It just sees an image of
the street ahead of it.
And it needs to explore
and sort of load up
its brain, its
own neural memory,
with all of this information.
MELANIE WARRICK:
My understanding
from the way your
network structure
works is that it's
modular, and it's
usable for transfer learning to
be able to move from one city
to another city.
RAIA HADSELL: After we
figured out that this did work
and that we could train an
agent to move around one city,
we thought, well,
that's interesting,
but it's doing that a
lot because it's just
memorizing the city.
And we said we want to be
able to have an agent that
can navigate not
just in New York,
but then in London and in Paris.
And if it gets to a new
city, there are some things
that we have to learn.
We have to learn where
the neighborhoods are
and what the landmarks look
like, things like this.
But there's a lot of things
that we carry with us.
There's a lot of
transfer of information
that we do from city to city.
And so we wanted to see
if that was the case.
So we built an architecture that
was more modular, where there's
part of it that is
general and that
is applied to each new
city, and there's part of it
that's just city-specific.
And over time, that part
of the neural network
that is city-specific learns
to encode just the details.
Where's the Eiffel Tower or
where are the best bridges
across the Thames?
What does Central
Park look like?
Learns these specific things.
And the two work very well
just being trained together.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
you can plug and play
those a little bit more.
And that's a
recurrent neural net
that holds the policy
for the location base.
RAIA HADSELL: That's right.
It's a LST, a long
short term memory.
MELANIE WARRICK: I've
heard about grid cells.
Can you tell us a little bit
about what grid cells are
and how they play a
role in this research?
RAIA HADSELL: When we think
about biological navigation
or biological spatial
understanding,
we think about
these neurons that
have been found in the
brains of mice and rats
that are called place
cells and grid cells.
There's a few other types.
There's border cells,
head direction cells,
but can focus on place
cells and grid cells.
And there's been
amazing research.
The Nobel Prize was just won a
few years ago by Edward Moser,
who discovered the grid cells.
These are neurons in
two areas of the brain.
And grid cells are very
general, and they just
measure how far it is
that we're walking,
that we're moving along.
So think about it as if
I walk down a street,
then I'm going to have
a neuron in my brain
that's counting every one
meter, and it's firing every one
meter that I step.
There's another one that's
firing every meter and a half
when I take a step, when I
get to each meter and half.
Another one that might only
fire every 10 meters as I'm
walking along.
And these are hexagonally
arranged in the brain,
so their reactivity
is hexagonal as you
walk through the environment.
And they give a way of measuring
both direction and distance.
So when I take a nice,
complicated path wandering
around my neighborhood,
say, at home,
if you ask me at any
point to stop and point
back to where my home is,
I can just reach out an arm
and point straight back to
where home is, even if I've
taken some circuitous route.
We think that's
because of grid cells.
Place cells are different.
Place cells memorize
a specific place.
You have a place cell that goes
off in the kitchen of your home
and nowhere else in the
world, or at least you
can think about it
that way, as being
a unique identifier for
different places in the world.
MELANIE WARRICK: Interesting.
RAIA HADSELL: So
one of the things
that we found a
few years ago, when
we started doing this
navigation research using
recurrent neural nets, is
that if we trained an agent
to simply move around
an environment,
accumulate its estimate
of where it was over time,
so basically be able to do that
pointing task, that what we
would get is inside
that neural network,
we would get something that
looked a lot like grid cells.
And we did some
more tests and did
a lot of different
experiments, and we just
published our results
last month in "Nature".
And this is a joint work
between the neuroscience group
here at DeepMind and
the deep learning group.
And it was very
interesting to find
that these types of neurons
that underpin spatial navigation
in mice and rats look very,
very similar to the grid
cells, the neurons that we have
in our completely artificial
neural networks
that we're training.
So that points to some
fundamental similarities.
MARK MANDEL: So I'm
actually quite curious,
because this is
fascinating, was it
the plan to build something
that works the way,
say, like a brain works?
Or was it that you
were doing this work,
and we just found
out after the fact
that oh, this actually
seems to be working
the same way most brains work?
RAIA HADSELL: Well, it
was a little bit of both.
My colleagues Andrea
Banino and Dharshan,
we were working on this
from the beginning together.
So they were talking
about grid cells
and I was talking about robots.
But we were working on the
same code base, same thing.
And so we really just started
looking for it at the same time
that it was there.
You know, that's
how research works.
It was an exciting
discovery, though.
And then it took a
couple more years
to really convince ourselves
this was what we were seeing,
and also to demonstrate
if you train
the neural network in such a way
that these grid cells emerge,
that the agent that
has those grid cells
can then do things like
shortcut navigation.
It can take a shortcut in
the same way that we can.
Agents that don't
have that are going
to retrace their
own paths again.
So it completely
changes the behavior
of the agent in terms
of being able to point
towards where you want to go
and find that shortcut if it's
there.
A lot of other types
of behavior as well.
But basically we
were trying to repeat
some of the fundamental
work experiments that
were done with rodents and
see if they applied also
to our agents.
And just to be clear,
although most of the research
has been done with
mice and rats,
neuroscientists are quite
certain that grid cells
and place cells are something
that exists in all mammals,
or at least most mammals.
There are 3D grid cells
in bats, for instance.
MELANIE WARRICK: So is the
shortcuts one of the surprises
that you found in the research?
Is there other
surprises that you've
seen that you didn't expect?
RAIA HADSELL: That's
a good question.
The shortcuts were exciting
because they weren't actually
surprise.
We predicted that.
And then it took us a
long time to come up
with the experiments that
would actually prove it.
And that's exactly how
you want it to work.
You want to have a hypothesis
and then eventually be
able to demonstrate it.
I find the reason why I love
doing reinforcement learning
is because you're
training agents
that end up with some behavior.
And you don't know what
that's going to be in advance.
And you can train
agents that cheat
in many, many different ways.
For instance, I work in
manipulation as well,
with robot manipulation,
trying to pick up objects.
Think about how do I train
a robot arm to pick up
a ball off of a tabletop?
And you say, well, you're
going to give that robot
a reward if it gets the
ball to 10 centimeters off
of the tabletop.
So what does the
agent learn to do?
It learns to simply flick
the ball, for instance,
so that it bounces into the
air, which is easier, in a way,
than actually picking it up.
Since we use simulators
a lot, agents
are extremely good at finding
the bugs in the simulator.
If you want to find a
bug in your simulator,
you train an agent.
It's going to find the bug
in the simulator in some way
of reward hacking, call it.
MELANIE WARRICK: Sounds
like some good opportunities
around security.
RAIA HADSELL: Yes, exactly.
This is done in
security research.
MELANIE WARRICK:
So what are some
of the challenges
you had, especially
when you were doing
the research in terms
of street wise navigation?
RAIA HADSELL: Scaling it
to very large environments
was definitely challenging.
We spent a lot of
time just saying,
how can we run on an area
the size of New York that's
got 80,000 nodes in
that graph, panoramas
that we're working with?
I can give most of
the credit there
to Piotr Mirowski, who is the
lead author on that paper,
actually.
And he really was able to
make that work, both through--
architecturally, coming
up with better ways
to manage memory and manage
TensorFlow, et cetera.
Also, algorithmically training
the agent with a curriculum,
so it starts out learning
about places that are close by,
and then its horizons
expand and it eventually
learns the entire city.
So that was a challenge.
Any time that we work with
actual real robots, that's
a challenge.
You know, it feels,
at least, like it's
90% solving problems that
are not interesting, not
publishable, not
important, but they
have to be solved
so that you can
do the 10% of exciting
real research.
MARK MANDEL: So to
maybe bring it back
to a practical
level in some ways,
so this seems to be useful
for navigation stuff.
Is it just useful there?
Like where can we see
people, eventually, at least,
using this research?
RAIA HADSELL: I think that if I
want to find my way across New
York, I'm going
to use Google Maps
and the very standard algorithms
that are used there, very good
algorithms to do routing.
But I think that there's reasons
where we might want to say just
based on the visual
information, what can I see here
and what can I infer?
So for instance, a blind
person that wants to navigate
and wants an assistant
might not just
want to know where to
turn, which Google Maps can
give that information, but also
what does the street look like,
and some other information
about what is there visually,
or some notion of how
navigation would work
from the point of a
visually-based algorithm,
rather than an algorithm that
knows the underlying map.
There's other interesting ways
in which one could use this.
If you've ever tried to
navigate around a city
where you don't
know the language,
it can make it very hard
because you don't know how
to read the street signs, even.
So being told to turn
right on street x
isn't meaningful if you
don't know the language
or don't know the
alphabet, in particular.
So there, I think that we
could give more semantically
guided information that's
based on the visual appearance
of the area.
More fundamentally,
I'm hoping that we
will be able to continue
to give information
to the neuroscientists about
the ways in which these things
might work in the brain.
One of the applications
there is that they've
discovered that the
grid cells in the brain
are very related to
Alzheimer's disease.
And so there's a strong
relationship there in that,
if your grid cells are
not performing well,
then you're more likely to
be in stages of Alzheimer's.
So I'm not sure what we can
do with that connection.
But it's very interesting.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Well, and that's
how usually research
goes a lot of times.
You don't know where
that's going to go yet.
But still, the potential
is exciting in some ways.
If somebody wanted to
explore the work that you've
done recently, see
how they could use it
in their own research,
how would you
recommend them exploring it?
What resources would you suggest
that they check out, especially
for reinforcement learning?
RAIA HADSELL: Yeah.
There's a lot of good
material on the DeepMind site.
We have all of these
blog posts that both
give you a really nice
high level understanding,
and also give you some resources
at the end of that blog post
to drill deeper, to
go to other articles
or go to the actual
journal publication.
That's probably
where I would start.
MELANIE WARRICK:
I'm curious, too,
what's something that you've
seen in the robotics research
space in general in the recent
years that would have blown
your mind several years back
if you think about it now?
RAIA HADSELL: So the
work that Boston Dynamics
has done in robotics
has always been amazing
and years ahead of its time.
So this is the Atlas robot
that now can do backflips.
And Spot Mini, the dog-like
robot from Boston Dynamics
that can open doors and
navigate incredibly well.
Of course, I am going
to say that these
don't use any machine
learning, or very
little machine learning.
And that's actually
great for us who
do learning-based
robotics because it
sets the bar really high.
And I'm really excited
to see if some point,
we can have humanoid robots
doing backflips from a machine
point of view instead of
a optimization and control
perspective.
On the learning side,
I think that the work
of the group at UC Berkeley
has been really amazing.
They've been able to
have robots do things
like tie knots in ropes
after a single demonstration
by a human of the type of knot
that they'd like to be tied,
or robots opening
door knobs and such.
Also work that they've done
with the group at Google Brain.
MELANIE WARRICK:
This is wonderful.
And I know we're
running low on time.
Raia, was there
anything else that you
wanted to mention that we
hadn't already covered?
Or are you going to be
speaking somewhere soon?
RAIA HADSELL: I just came
back from a conference,
so I'm on my way to a summer
school where I'll be talking,
the Transylvanian Machine
Learning Summer School.
I don't have any big talks
planned until next year,
probably.
But we're just at the beginning
of really understanding AI
and how--
there's a lot of things
that we call AI algorithms,
but real AI is where we start to
understand more about cognition
and the human brain.
And I think we're just starting
to scratch the surface of that.
And I find it
thrilling, not just
for the types of discoveries
and types of scientific research
that we can do with this,
but also because it helps
us understand the human mind.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
Thank you again for joining us.
We really appreciate giving
the insights about the research
you're doing around navigation,
around reinforcement learning.
RAIA HADSELL: Thanks, Melanie.
Thanks, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you so much.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Thanks again, Raia,
for coming onto the podcast,
spending some time with us
to explain what your
team has been researching
and getting a little bit more
familiar with reinforcement
learning.
I think now it's time for us to
dive into question of the week.
How do you connect to Google
Cloud Source repository
to an existing Git repository?
MARK MANDEL: This is
an interesting question
and something I've
tackled myself.
So if you're familiar
with Google Cloud Source
Repositories, they're basically
our hosted private Git source
repositories.
But you may already have, say,
a GitHub repo or a Bitbucket
repo, or maybe you host
your own git instance
on something else, maybe
something like GitLab.
And you want to be able to
connect that existing Git
repo to a Google Cloud
Source Repository,
maybe because that's
just where it is.
You could always use Google
Cloud Source Repository
by itself, which is fine.
But maybe you want pull
requests or some other features
we don't necessarily have.
But you may want to connect to
Google Cloud Source Repository
because that's where all
the hooks are for things
like Container Builder, a
lot of our debugging tools
that require source,
things like that.
So there are definitely
a few options.
So if you're working
on GitHub or Bitbucket,
we already have integrations.
So you can basically
go to Connecting
to a GitHub Repository in
the Google Cloud console.
We have basically
some drop downs
that you can fill
in all the details
for your GitHub or your
Bitbucket repository
and all that kind of stuff.
And it'll automatically
synchronize between the two.
So that's already
pretty straightforward,
which is pretty nice.
And as those changes come in
from your outside repository,
then that can fire off
things like Container Builder
and things like that.
But it's also worth noting, and
I put a description in the show
notes as well, that
you can also manually
do this as well if you
have a custom setup
or something like that.
The way I've done this in the
past, and it works quite well,
there's a relatively easy way
to marry Git repositories.
And so you can set up
just a cron job that
says something
like a GCE instance
that basically mirrors
the repository,
and then the cron job will
just immediately fetch
what's on the
remirror over and over
again and push those details up.
And that works really,
really well as well.
I've done that, and it
works really nicely.
And then you can hook
up all your things
that work with Google
Cloud Source Repositories.
MELANIE WARRICK: Well, thank you
for giving us all that insight.
So Mark, where are you going
to be in the next month?
MARK MANDEL: Next?
Well I'll be at Next next.
MELANIE WARRICK: Oh yeah?
Will you be at Next?
MARK MANDEL: Next
week I'll be at Next.
MELANIE WARRICK: No.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, the
next next week I'm at Next.
MELANIE WARRICK: There you go.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
And you'll be there
too, I believe.
MELANIE WARRICK: We will
both be at Next next week.
And we will have a
booth that people should
come by and say hi to us.
We will definitely be there in
the mornings and a little bit
in the afternoons.
We'll have some
swag to give out.
There's some stuff in particular
that you should come by early
because we may run out.
But we always have some other
things like stickers and shirts
that we will have probably
throughout the day.
So yeah, come by.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
definitely come by.
I'll be speaking on
[INAUDIBLE] as well.
So if you're interested on
open source and game stuff,
I'll be there.
We actually were trying
to look at what are
our favorite talks going to be.
But there is so much
content we didn't
have enough time this morning.
So I'm kind of amazed at
the amount of stuff that's
going to be happening at Next.
I'm really excited to see what
happens this year, and also
super excited to
meet, everyone who
listens to the podcast and the
wider Google Cloud community.
They're always
really lovely people.
MELANIE WARRICK:
And we have a lot
of people who we're going
to be interviewing, too.
That'll be fun.
And then I'm also actually,
right before Next,
going to be giving a
talk at PyCon Russia.
So if you're out there
for that conference,
you should definitely find me.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
Awesome.
Well, Melanie, thank
you for joining me
for yet another
episode of the podcast.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Thank you, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: And thank
you all for listening.
And we'll see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]